uh have you checked gas prices lately
have you checked the interest rates
absolutely we're in a recession
we're not currently in a recession and
we possibly could be heading to one but
i think that's yet to be seen not in one
now uh i think we're hitting one soon
though
because you know prices keep going up
and up you know after the pandemic
people are buying more stuff going out
doing things again
um
and you know wages aren't going to
adjust that fast so people aren't going
to have the money to to you know to
adjust to these new prices so they're
gonna start buying less and then you
know people lose jobs people don't want
to buy anything so jobs go out
um and overall just you know less
economic
anything going forward i think oh i
think we're in a recession
interest rates has gone up
up
the economy seems to be slowing down the
price of cars is unreal
if you can get one
you know supply and demand is out of
sync something fears
um i believe we are in a recession and
unfortunately i don't think we've ever
really recovered from the last recession
at this point i think it's going to get
worse because prices are going up and
employment pay is not going up as fast
as prices is so it's going to be a lot
more people being hurt by what's
happening around as far as our spending
and what we would like to enjoy
and know that a lot of us will not be
able to enjoy we're just going to be
after work to be able to pay bills to
live to eat
for me personally um i'm
been fortunate enough in my life that to
make some good decisions and we're in a
comfortable spot but at the same time i
see how it's affecting my family my
friends and the simple cost of goods
going up
it's concerning things are picking up i
believe things are picking up you know
we have faith in one another
and with that faith in each other we'll
be able to overcome the economy i think
some people are probably worse off than
others depending on you know where they
are in their life and
how much they've managed to save and
they can live off their savings when
things are more expensive but for some
people it's probably tough the the
country the
economy isn't growing
don't seem to be grown anyways
we can't keep up with anything i mean
honestly i think the leadership is very
poor
even to the past that we are actually
going to be looking at the next election
and trump is still trying to run again
i don't see it perceived as a better
economical standards for the poor people
the rich will continue to be rich and
the poor will continue to get poor